in this research lab haye discovered
story that is swift li xin jing world
history that have the power to change
the way we produce material the way it
is the way we kill it is the story of
deep tech deep tech in the new chapter
in the innovation  story bringing
together sayans engineering and design
thinking imagine iphone pandemic global offer
apple and drugs all
fight it was develop a
approve our indiecade
heuers month or even in weeks from ipek
of this potential emerging technology is
like robotics synthetic biology
nanomaterials blocks chain quantum
computing  and many others wayne combined
with each other humble ended with
engineering and design days are making
watts simbin possible possible so what
is deep tech high speed the last et
inland visiting one hundred research
labs une start up from shenzhen in china
tour haifa israël 1 10 6  watts and their
surroundings diptyque ventures and focus in
fundamental issued identifies physics
and cons  traints of industry is not sold
strong said kate for example in
nuclear energy was young e-mobility
and taxi dresses the work at the
crossroads of emerging technology
licensing biology custom programming
artificial intelligence and many others
and focus in physics al project
using data en digital  platform to
accelerate test and learn
zelaya fault an ecosystem to accelerate the
innovation michael including the
bild ntes failed to many discipline a
necessary to master fort wayne venture
all gordon it is about cooperation note
competition deep tech is ultimate lee
transforming discovery into the design
and  engineering exercise so why does it
matters it matters because it is
happening now all roads and growing this
approach is changing what was once
considered in possible in to something
actively possible all tec
spacek this diptych pioneer or disrupted
0 space industry by producing radiated
bell rocket  pei chips reducing the
cost of going to spa  e lessor factors
often that she does is by combining
advanced materials and chemical
develops in the last one two years with
vertical integration and then modular
approach of modern software engineering
or pascal the start up founded by several
shades of my friend looking creative
and  using fundamental physx combined
with software engineering and data
science everything created is an analogue
let's count processor out of tech boston
begin guinea pigs works founded by internet
pioneer tome night
the group done mighty scientist visit to
hot gecko mignola ben ayad never seen
before he saw fully automated bayhawks
lab  with the latest robotics technics
halloween everything is thousands of
biological designs
that she is by building the
largest internal meta genomics database of
cell and size and genetic programming by
combining robotics proteins design both
in my co-organisait mme hanna mariën
cells and data signs  that built russell
programming platform hebel all
cried  ient nearly n' y organized want by
combining science technology and
attainment of talent platform them to
become said amazon web service is of
biology les ting start up and other
companies user facilities this is
perfect example ovi ecosystems
operating so right now many of you  may
be thinking how do i managed
technological risk will investors be
ready to play the deep in game
yes there is
a developing deep tech
requires tourists sink or innovation
approach high as seen that for rules
govern successfull d'ipek ventures  rolls
number one by problem orients help
our technology focus you this is very
important mini d'ipic ventures start
or solutions in search of the
guines problem that partners louise by her
to solve the nitrogen fertilizers ychoux
nitrogen is the most viewed fertilizers
in  the world today small product 6
sweepé saint olle greenhouse gases a
lead poljud either are many start-ups
today a try to s  olve tichoux bahia
planning erp solutions
guines coach ou solvit mahias kingston
i know the way what if instead of
producing nitrogen we create bacteria
that use existing nitrogen
toufik cete it on the root of the
planes just like nature dose bearing
me to it is abbott combining interakting
converting so you need to bring cross
disciplinary tim herlihy we like said
ecosystems what does it mean concrete
li tec commonwealth merge system
an energy ventures focusing a nuclear
was young that she's the breakthrough in
nuclear was young con binding
adventures in hardware in datacenter
them to do  calculations a simulation
that was simply note of hubble chelios
back in the lady ecosystems very well
corporate like in eyes on writing nord
had invested in lionesses universities
the 15th haiti plasma science infuses
young centers to actively collaborating
wazemmes vis is like breakthrough energy
ventures and others are  supporting m
1.10 us government sims int  erested in
working with them rolls number three
adopts a design thinking approach
powered by deep tech identit failed in its
mission
early and to be tested to reduce the
risk of thrones gas to working prototype
as quickly as possible anticipated
friction poynt athit stage of the
innovation saïkal  use to reach
digital platform to reduce the cost of
this town loeb liliam aviation le
diptyque start-up building all-electric
air taxi aiming at solving urban
mobility a start up by developing the
two sisters prototype the five sitters
using real-time data of  every flight to
design the next version strongman role
adopt a design to cost approach
merging signs with engineering required
to be economics in mind all the time
that mother jane and other synthetic
biology lighthouse whenever the design
project user ruthless designed to coast
approach in  the design file even before
production start the look for the right
prodex at the right cost wizz air ride
paramete  rs zaïm ercan develops high
line and transparent
printers cooked flesh for electronics
produced by fermentation indices
bayonnaise film he's schipper un as
better properties zenzi exist in one
petroleum is down
deep tech ism turing quickly now in
twenty night in there were more than
life size and  deep tech ventures fuel by
fifty billions $ of investor 1 ml min 22
s coming out of research labs have the
power to alone foam tracing shoes
think what you would like to grow in
your world consider as ait d'ipek
help you cultivate hate that  since may be
by accelerating drug development or
by eliminating greenhouse gases hop et
rap ce bail solving de congestion
problem planning city dick tech in the
never grand an opportunity infront
havas waiting to be scalde for the
world's dead and is next chapter in
the innovation story  1 to day n nite owl
view to joy me in its creation 5 ue
[Music]